my name is Dolores Edmond and I am here  to warn you about fimble weed Park my  uncle built the town and the  world-famous pillow factory using his  brains sweat arrogance and ego symbol  weed Park was the center of the social  scene parties movie stars and the rich  and famous all drawn to its flickering  light of promise and vision of the  future then the factory fell on hard  times  everything slipped away and the town  descended into the shell of decay and  pity before you leaving the pillow  factory to me was my uncle's only plan  for redemption he knew I could see me  and him from ruin in the eyes of history  but I don't want to save it something  terrifying is happening something that  itches and Fester's and grows with each  scratch something I know my uncle  started and his death is making stronger  my name is Dolores Edmund I am one of  only five people that can prevent what  are careless ambition and reckless  dreams